MAMTHA: Hey.
Are you looking to both
manage and secure your APIs
on Google Cloud?
Google offers the
industry-leading API management
platform, Apigee.
And it's really
easy to get started.
My name is [? Mamtha. ?]
And I'm going
to show the setup and
configuration of Apigee API
management on your
Google Cloud project.
First, let's look at
some prerequisites.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You will need to
create or have access
to a Google Cloud project.
And that project should
have a cloud billing
account set for it.
Finally, the user
performing the setup
must have the right permissions.
If you have the editor
role on the project,
that will be more
than sufficient.
Now open the Google
Cloud Console,
select the project in which
you want to configure Apigee.
Then in the search bar,
type Apigee and then
click on the first link.
Alternatively, you can start
from the Apigee pricing page
and select pay as
you go option there.
Either way, you will be
redirected to the Apigee setup
page, click on Set Up Apigee.
This brings you to
the setup wizard.
There are four steps.
First, you need to enable
the APIs for Apigee
and its dependencies.
These are services,
or capabilities,
within Google Cloud that
are required by Apigee.
Click the Enable API button.
And the wizard will do the work.
It takes 30 seconds or so.
When you see the blue check
mark, that means it's finished.
Click Next.
Steps two let you configure
service networking to set
a private connection between
your network, Apigee,
and Cloud Services.
If you have a default VPC
network in your project,
the wizard will pre-select as
it is the authorized network.
These are often
the right choices.
But you can click the Edit
button to make your own choice.
If you don't yet have a VPC
network, you'll need to pause
and go and create one.
Follow the link shown here.
After you select and confirm the
network and subnet, click Next.
The visit configures
the connection
between the VPC and
the Google services
to use IP address within
the allowed ranges.
In step three,
hosting an encryption,
here you choose the TCP region
that will host your Apigee
runtime, the gateway
that handle API traffic,
and the GCP region that will
store your analytics data.
They can be different
or the same.
You can choose any GCP
regions for the runtime.
But there are more limited set
of choices for the analysis
data.
Along with the
region selection, you
can choose the Google
Cloud managed encryption
or your own encryption for
your runtime instance and data.
Again, in this step,
default configurations
are pre-selected.
Click Edit to modify them.
When you are
satisfied, click Next.
In step four, you can
choose whether to allow
inbound requests from internet
to reach Apigee, or allow
only inbound requests if they
originate from within the VPC.
I will choose to allow
external access to API proxies
by selecting Enable
Internet Access.
We will choose an
automatically-generated domain,
subnet, and SSL certificates.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
After that, click Submit to
begin provisioning process.
In general, the provisioning
process takes up to 40 minutes
to complete.
Check back later to find my
Apigee organization all set up
with pay-as-you-go billing.
Congratulations.
Your Apigee
organization is ready.
Once this is done,
I can now start
creating my first
API proxy and explore
the awesomeness of Apigee.
That is the topic
of the next video.
You can start provisioning
your Apigee organization today.
Or if you want to
explore further,
check our further videos and
resources in the link below.